بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله
صاحب السمو الملكي ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان رئيس مجلس الوزراء الساده اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو معالي السيد احمد
ابو الغيظ الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه
السيدات والساده والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تعالى وبركاته
اود في البدء التعبير عن تهانينا الصادقه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
لتسممها رئاسه هذه الدوره المهمه
ونثقوا انكم سمو الامير ستقودون اعمالها
نحو النجاح المنشود
كما نشكر جمهوريه الجزائر الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه الشقيقه على مبادلته من جهود
دؤوبه خلال رئاستها الاجتماعات القمه
السابقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم اتشرف
بمخاطبتكم اليوم
بتكليف من شقيقكم الفريق والركنه عبد
الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
والذي
يبلغكم تحياته وقد حاله
الظروف التي تعلمونها دون تواجده بينكم
اليوم
فهو الان بين قواته يقود معركه الكرامه
ضد قوات التمرد التي اطلقت رصاصه الغدر
والخيانه صبيحه يوم السبت الخامس عشر من
ابريل الماضي عندما هاجمت منزل سيادته
وعددا من المنشات العسكريه والمطارات بهدف
الاستيلاء على السلطه في الوقت الذي كانت
تمارس فيه الخداع
بالدعاء هازيفا انها تدعم التحول
الديمقراطي
وهو كان وما زال هو المطلب الاساسي لثوره
السودانيه
السيد الرئيس
تصدت قواتنا المسلحه ببساله للقوات
المتمرده وكان يمكنها حسم المعرفه في وقت
وجيز لولا ان تلك القوات التي يناهز عددها
الثمانين الف تسللت داخل الاحياء السكنيه
واتخذت من المؤسسات الخدميه والمستشفيات
والمنازل ثكنات عسكريه واحتجزت المدنيين
الابرياء العزل بمن فيهم كبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه والنساء والاطفال دروعا
بشريه ومارست اسوا انواع الجرائم من قتل
ونهب وسلب واغتصاب في انتهاك صارخ للقانون
الدولي الانساني
وانعانا في انتهاكاتها لم تلتزم حركه
التمرد بكل اتفاقات الهدنه وواصلت جرائمها
لتشمل البعثات الدبلوماسيه فاعتدد على
سفاره المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
الملحقيتين العسكريه والثقافيه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وسفاره دوله الكويت وسفاره جمهوريه
الصومال الفيدراليه وقتلت مساعد نائب
الملحق الاداري بسفاره جمهوريه مصر
العربيه
واقتحمت وسلبت مقر المنظمه العربيه
للتنميه الزراعيه التابعه للجامعه العربيه
وعدد كبير من السفارات الاجنبيه الاخرى
وذلك في انتهاك سافر لاتفاقيه فيينا
للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه وفي ضوء ما اشرت
اليه من انتهاكات السيد الرئيس سمو الامير
يقلقنا غض المجتمع الدولي الطرف عن هذه
الانتهاكات التي تستوجب الشجب والادانه
والمساءله
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ان حكومه
السودان استجعارا لمسؤوليتها تجاه
مواطنيها واحساسا
بمعاناتهم وما يتعرضون له من انتهاكات من
القوات المتمرده قبلت
مبادره الهدنه الانسانيه التي تقدمت بها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ونحن في السودان مطمئنون باننا سنتجاوز
هذه المحنه بوحدتنا وقوه ارادتنا
ومؤازرتكم
ومساندتكم المعهوده والتي تم تاكيدها في
القرار الذي اعتمدتموه اليوم حيث عبر عن
تضامنكم مع حكومه السودان وربط التدخل
الاجنبي في شؤون السودان الداخليه واكد ان
الازمه الحاليه شان داخلي واما على شرعيه
الحكومه ومؤسسات الدوله واحترام السياده
الوطنيه والاستجابه لنداء المساعدات
الانسانيه السيد الرئيس نحن في حكومه
السودان لسنا دعاه حرب لكنها فرضت علينا
واذا ما جنحت القوات المتمرده للسلم سنجنح
له واذا وضعوا السلاح سيتم العفو عنهم بل
وان ابواب القوه القوات المسلحه السودانيه
مشرعه لدمجهم ان رغبوا ولكن في ذات الوقت
اؤكد لكم ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه بما
عرف عنها عبر عقود من الزمان من كفاءه
واقدام وشجاعه ومهنيه عاليه
قادره على هزيمه التمرد فلا مجال للتشكيك
فيها كيف لا
كيف لا وجيشنا الوطني تربى على عقيده
حذاري ان وطنك يضام
وحذاري ان يصبح حطام وتربى على نحن في
الشده باس يتجلى ويعرفهم التاريخ فلا دوره
ولا مجال للتشكيك فيها اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو تعلمون ان السودان في
اقليم كبير يضم عشر دول في جوار مباشر
وغير مباشر هو بمثابه صمام الامان وواسطه
العقد لهذا الاقليم ولكم من تتخيلوا اذا
من فرط هذا العقد لا قدر الله كيف ستكون
تداعياته على الاقليم باسره
لذلك نثق لكم ستقفون مع السودان لاحتواء
هذه الازمه وسترافقونه في المرحله القادمه
لاعاده التاهيل والاعمار لما احدثه التمرد
من دمار للبنت تحتيه والمؤسسات ختاما
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
يستبشر السودان ببوادر السلام التي اخذت
تتبلور في المنطقه العربيه بعوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايران والتي تؤكد على حرص وسعي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لتحقيق الاستقرار والامن
في المنطقه ونحن نثمن دورها عاليا ونعلمه
تماما
كما يرحب السودان بعوده الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه للجامعه العربيه ويثمن
جهود لجنه الاتصال العربيه الوزاريه في
هذا الصدد وقد ظل السودان يدعو لعوده
سوريا الى بيت العرب وحرص على استمرار
علاقاته الدبلوماسيه معها اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو يؤكد السودان مجددا موقفه
الثابت من القضيه الفلسطينيه قضيه العربه
الاولى ويدين بشده الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ويرحب
باتفاق اطلاق النار الذي تم التوصل اليه
مؤخرا بفضل جهود الوساطه المصريه
في الختام يود وابدا بلادي ان اعبر عن
فائق الشكر والتقدير للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه على حفاوه الاستقبال
وكرم الضيافه والشكر والتقدير يمتد لمعالي
الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
والامانه العامه على حسن تنظيم فعاليات
هذه القمه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
[تصفيق]